[Música]
eeuu cerrará su espacio aéreo a las
aeronaves rusas así lo ordenó el
presidente joe biden quien dedicó gran
parte de su primer discurso del estado
de la unión a criticar el accionar del
mandatario ruso vladimir putin
sin embargo hayden reiteró que no
enviara tropas a ucrania ampliamos desde
washington
mientras tanto rusia cierra el cerco a
kiev la capital ucraniana un misil
explotó contra la principal torre de
televisión de esta ciudad y tropas rusas
aterrizan en hardcore la segunda más
grande del país
desde disney apple hasta el comité
olímpico y la fifa castigan a rusia por
su invasión a ucrania
varias compañías decidieron dejar de
vender sus productos en territorio ruso
y deportistas de este país están siendo
aislados de las competencias
internacionales
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es la calle y es un
placer estar con ustedes el presidente
de eeuu joe biden dedico el inicio de su
primer discurso del estado de la unión
americana a la guerra en ucrania el
mandatario criticó la decisión de su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin de invadir
territorio ucraniano hayden afirmó que
moscú no esperaba que occidente
reaccionará pero que las naciones de
este lado del mundo están listas y
unidas reiteró que las tropas
norteamericanas no irán a combatir
directamente a los rusos escuchemos lo
que dijo el mandatario
nuestras fuerzas no
entrarán no van a entrar en conflicto
con fuerzas rusas en ucrania nuestras
fuerzas no van a ir a europa a combatir
en ucrania sino a defender a sus aliados
se notan en el evento que putin decida
seguir moviéndose hacia el occidente por
ese propósito hemos movilizado tropas
estadounidenses escuadrones aéreos
navíos para proteger a los países del
otan incluyendo a polonia rumanía
lituania letonia y estonia y dejado
bastante claro que los estados unidos y
nuestros aliados dependerán cada pulgada
de territorio que acá parte de la otan
con toda la fuerza de nuestro poder
colectivo cada pulgada
y ampliamos lo que dijo el mandatario
joe biden con nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal vázquez cristóbal
explíquenos un poco que fueron las
palabras de joe biden frente a la guerra
en ucrania
diez minutos más o menos fue lo que yo
bailé destino al tema de ucrania en este
en este su primer discurso del estado de
la unión resaltó y fue algo noticioso
cuando hizo el anuncio de que los no no
se podrá usar el espacio aéreo
estadounidense para que aviones rusos
pues pues vuelen sobre este hizo el
anuncio también de que el departamento
de justicia va a empezar a investigar
con más precisión los oligarcas rusos
que tienen propiedades acá en eeuu se
refirió a los yates a los apartamentos
de lujo a las inversiones que tienen
estos oligarcas en eeuu y él dijo que
tiene los ojos puestos en ellos y se le
escapó una frase que llamó mucho la
atención entre algunos analistas y es
que le dijo a putin ya estos oligarcas
es que no saben lo que se les vienen
temas de sanciones y en temas de la
fuerza de respuesta en temas de más
presión financiera de parte de eeuu
hacia rusia hay que resaltar también que
sea putin dijo que yo vaya dijo que
usted está completamente equivocado al
creer que iba a dividir más a occidente
que esto y su ataque a ucrania terminó
uniendo más a occidente y que cuando los
dictadores hacen esto sí tiene un precio
para los estadounidenses pero que al
final pues terminó generando mucha más
unión acá en estados unidos con sus
aliados europeos
cristóbal y muy brevemente cuáles fueron
los otros temas de la política interna
de los que hablo baida
sin duda el tema de la pandemia trató de
resaltar sus logros en cuanto a la
pandemia hay que mencionar que a partir
de hoy en eeuu el uso de la máscara ya
no es obligatorio eso redujo las
presiones de las manifestaciones que se
habían anunciado aquí en washington y
pues se permitió que el ambiente fuera
un poco más fresco en cuanto a la
pandemia sobre el tema de la inflación
resaltó que pues se necesita hacer mucho
más al respecto dijo que el gasto
público el gasto público de miles 200
millones de dólares que todavía no ha
sido aprobado en el congreso
precisamente porque el propio partido
demócrata no lo ha permitido ese gasto
público según analistas que él citó pues
va a
bajar la presión inflacionaria en el
país y no a subir la inflación como
critican muchos republicanos se resaltó
el tema también desde el los impuestos
que tienen que pagar empezar a pagar las
escuelas empresas más grandes en este
país gracias cristóbal por este reporte
ucrania entró en su séptimo día de
guerra y en el sexto que es la capital y
la segunda ciudad más grande harkov
fueron blanco de una serie de ataques
por parte de rusia y es que la principal
torre de televisión de kiev fue atacada
lo que muestra el cerco del kremlin a
esta capital como ven en sus pantallas
la torre está ubicada en el radio de
menos de 20 kilómetros de kiev allí las
fuerzas rusas también atacaron lugares
civiles como el monumento al holocausto
además tropas enviadas por moscú
aterrizaron en hardcore
ante este panorama cada vez más civiles
ucranianos están tomando las armas para
defender al país frente a la invasión
rusa algo que el gobierno del presidente
de volodymyr selenski incentivo al
repartir más de 18 mil fusiles y al
prohibir la salida del país de los
hombres que tengan entre 18 y 60 años
sin embargo distintas organizaciones
advierten que es un peligro armar a los
civiles alva santana tiene los detalles
con la invasión de rusia a ucrania son
muchos los ciudadanos que están
dispuestos a resistir hasta el punto de
armarse con rifles y fusiles para hacer
frente a las tropas rusas
definitivamente estoy en contra de la
guerra así que espero que termine antes
de que tenga que usar mi arma contra
humanos pero por si acaso dado que es mi
tierra la defender y proteger a mi
familia mi casa mis seres queridos
robots y es que ahora el día a día de
los ucranianos gira en torno a la guerra
esta antigua fábrica de cerveza del pib
ahora se dedica a producir y distribuir
cócteles mólotov en los últimos días ha
distribuidos cientos de ellos por toda
la ciudad para reforzar las defensas
civiles locales
producimos bastantes miles de hecho
proporcionamos a las fuerzas de defensa
territorial locales para que estuvieran
preparados en caso de que los soldados y
los tanques rusos y eran acá y también
enviamos algunos aquí y en las
diferentes ciudades en las que necesitan
resistir las operaciones militares
el ejército ruso es el segundo más
poderoso del mundo el de ucrania ocupa
el número 22 es inferior con menos
vehículos militares y artillería motivo
por el que el presidente de volodymyr de
lenski pidió a los ciudadanos que se
armarán y pedíamos para proteger nuestra
tierra seguiremos entregando armas a
todos los que estén dispuestos a
tomarlas a todos los que están
dispuestos a proteger nuestra ciudad la
limited no obstante diferentes
organizaciones advierten de los dilemas
éticos sobre armar a civiles debido al
alto riesgo de enfrentarse a un ejército
profesional y bien armado
y por otro lado los intentos de aislar a
rusia se replican en los ámbitos de la
cultura y el deporte desde disney y
facebook hasta la fifa y el comité
olímpico están tomando acciones la
compañía más reciente deben hacerlo fue
apple que anunció que dejara de vender
sus productos en territorio ruso esta
empresa estadounidense dijo estar
preocupada por quienes serían por
quienes sufrían a causa de la invasión
en ucrania en el siguiente reporte les
contamos algunas de las medidas
la cultura la tecnología y el deporte
también aíslan a moscú tres grandes
estudios son disney y warner bros
suspendieron el estreno de sus películas
en rusia y el país no podrá competir en
el festival de la canción de eurovisión
2022 twitter facebook víctor y microsoft
tomaron medidas contra los medios de
comunicación respaldados por el kremlin
como rusia today y spot y tras la
decisión de la unión europea de bloquear
su emisión y apple deja de vender sus
productos del territorio ruso el mundo
del deporte también castigó a rusia
belarús luego de conocerse las medidas
de la fifa y la uefa en el fútbol que
entre otras cosas excluyen a la
selección rusa de la próxima copa del
mundo otros organismos se han sumado a
las sanciones como la unión ciclista
internacional que excluyó a todos los
equipos de rusia y belarús de sus
competencias y la federación
internacional de tenis que marginó a
estos países de sus torneos
internacionales y obligó a sus tenistas
a jugar bajo una bandera neutral
el gobierno ruso rechazó las medidas las
estradas ciudad nuestro país siempre se
ha herido el principio de que el deporte
está más allá de la política pero
estamos constantemente traídos por
política porque entienden la importancia
del deporte en la vida del pueblo ruso
carlos garcía debido a la crisis y el
establecimiento de una ley marcial en
ucrania los boxeadores alexander husic
campeón mundial del peso pesado y vasyl
lomachenko dejaron el ring de sus
entrenamientos para sumarse a los
batallones de defensa de su país
sigan con nosotros
[Música]